what's your one word to describe season
eight shift shift yeah well cuz I from
the looks of the footage I've seen we've
kind of gone from panty gate to pals
with Doreen yeah and that's a much
better way to have it in my opinion
yeah I'd much rather be pals then have a
conflict for sure you have to cut the
head off the devil I'm not going to tell
you who the devil is you have to watch
and find out but yeah I think that there
is the very normal and expected conflict
in a show seven strong women together
something's gonna happen yeah for sure
what's the one thing we do need to know
about Teddy heading into the season you
know I think Teddy has an interesting
story that she's willing to share about
her her fitness and her journey her
personal story which I think will be
inspirational I know she's an
accountability coach did she keep the
women accountable this season I don't
need anyone to keep me accountable I'm
pretty good on my own new music it's
kind of teased in the first episode yes
I'm in the studio if I could get a day
off great yeah we're making some great
new music I'm super excited it's
actually over do you kind of tease maybe
it's gonna be a ballad in the first
episode well there's a collection of
songs so I'm making any piece so one of
them will be enough so it's not just
singles game right now
you